SEA IN ODESA, AND HERE WITH ME,
JIM SCIUTTO, WHO START MESSAGE
OUT WITH A LOOK AT THE BIG
PICTURE.
>> Reporter: UKRAINIAN FORCES
HAVE SO FAR MANAGED TO HOLD ON
TO THE CAPITAL KYIV, DEFYING
U.S. INTELLIGENCE ASSESSMENTS,
DESPITE THE INCREASING INTENSITY
OF THE RUSSIAN ONSLAUGHT.
BUT U.S. OFFICIALS ARE NOW
WARNING THAT RUSSIA COULD SOON
INCREASE THE INTENSITY OF THEIR
ATTACK.
>> THEY HAVE SUFFERED SETBACKS,
BUT I DON'T THINK WE CAN JUST
ASSUME THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
STAY SETBACK.
>> SATELLITE IMAGES SHOW A
RUSSIAN MILITARY CONVOY GETTING
CLOSER TO KYIV FROM THE NORTH.
THE HEAD OF THE CONVOY MOST
RECENTLY OBSERVED AT AN AIRPORT
FEWER THAN 20 MILES FROM THE
CITY'S CENTER.
AS THE UKRAINIANS TRY TO HOLD
OFF THE RUSSIAN ADVANCE ACROSS
THE COUNTRY, THE U.S. AND ITS
ALLIES ARE KEEPING UP THE
PRESSURE ON THE FINANCIAL FRONT.
SANCTIONING RUSSIA'S CENTRAL
BANK.
ESSENTIALLY CUTTING OFF VLADIMIR
PUTIN'S ABILITY TO SUPPORT THE
RUSSIAN RUBLE, WHICH FELL AS
MUCH AS 30% ON MONDAY.
>> THESE ACTIONS WILL SEVERELY
IMPACT PUTIN INNER CIRCLE,
IMPEDE THE KREMLIN'S USE OF ITS
INTERNATIONAL RESERVES, AND
LIMIT ITS ABILITY TO FUND
ONGOING DESTABILIZING
ACTIVITIES.
>> Reporter: AND A HISTORIC
MOVE, EVEN SWITZERLAND, LONG A
BASTIAN OF NEUTRALITY HAS
MATCHED THE EUROPEAN UNION'S
SANCTIONS ON RUSSIA.
>> Translator: RUSSIA'S ATTACK
AGAINST UKRAINE IS UNACCEPTABLE
WITH REGARDS TO INTERNATIONAL
LAW.
UNACCEPTABLE POLITICALLY
SPEAKING AND UNACCEPTABLE FROM A
MORAL POINT OF VIEW.
>> Reporter: AS THE WAR
CONTINUES TO RAGE, RUSSIA HAS
COME TO THE NEGOTIATING TABLE
WITH UKRAINE.
UKRAINE SAYS THEIR PRIMARY AIM
IS A CEASE FIRE, AND CESSATION
OF HOSTILITIES.
RUSSIA SAYS THE TWO SIDES FOUND
POINTS WHERE THEY COULD MAKE
PROGRESS, A SECOND ROUND OF
TALKS WILL TAKE PLACE IN THE
COMING DAYS.
THOUGH UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY SOUNDED PESSIMISTIC
BEFORE THE TALKS BEGAN.
>> Translator: I DON'T REALLY
BELIEVE IN THE RESULT OF THIS
MEETING, BUT LET THEM TRY SO
THEN LATER ON NO CITIZEN OF
UKRAINE WOULD HAVE ANY DOUBT
THAT I, THE PRESIDENT, DID NOT
TRY TO STOP THE WAR WHEN I HAD A
CHANCE.
>> Reporter: TODAY THE U.S. MADE
A DIFFERENT KIND OF MOVE ON THE
DIPLOMATIC FRONT, EXPELLING 12
RUSSIAN DIPLOMATS PROSECUTE
U.N., ACCUSING THEM OF ESPIONAGE
ACTIVITIES BUT NOTING THIS
PROCESS HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR
SEVERAL MONTHS.
CNN REACHED OUT TO THE STATE
DEPARTMENT FOR COMMENT.
MILITARY AID IS STILL POURING
INTO UKRAINE.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
APPROVING ANOTHER $350 MILLION
OF SECURITY ASSISTANCE OVER THE
WEEKEND, AND EVEN SWEDEN, A
NON-NATO MEMBER ANNOUNCED THEY
WOULD BE SENDING 5,000 ANTI-TANK
WEAPONS, 5,000 HELMETS, 5,000
BODY SHIELDS AND 135,000 FIELD
RATIONS.
>> WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE SECURITY ASSISTANCE TO
UKRAINIAN ARMED FORCES.
THE UKRAINIANS HAVE BEEN
EFFECTIVE AT USING THESE WEAPONS
AND THESE SYSTEMS AND AT
RESISTING AND PUSHING BACK
RUSSIAN FORCES.
>> Reporter: GERMANY FINALLY
ANNOUNCED IT WOULD SEND WEAPONS
TO UKRAINE AS WELL.
AND HAS SAID IT WILL HIKE ITS
OWN DEFENSE SPENDING IN LIGHT OF
RUSSIA'S CONTINUED AGGRESSION.
>>.
>> Translator: PRESIDENT PUTIN
SHOULD NOT UNDERESTIMATE OUR
DETERMINATION TO DEFEND EVERY
SQUARE METER OF OUR ALLIANCE
TOGETHER WITH OUR ALLIES.
>> Reporter: THE LATEST
SATELLITE IMAGES SHOW THE SHEER
INTENSITY.
IT STRETCHES 40 MILES LONG,
IMAGINE THAT, FROM A POINT ABOUT
17 MILES NORTH OF THE CITY,
HEADING NORTH FROM THERE.
IT'S A COMBINATION OF TANKS,
ARMORED PERSONNEL CARRIERS,
SUPPLY VEHICLES, TOWED
HOWITZERS, THAT'S THE FORCE THAT
U.S. INTELLIGENCE BELIEVES
RUSSIA IS GOING TO ATTEMPT TO
SURROUND AND CIRCLE THE CAPITAL
AND THEN ATTEMPT FROM THERE
REALLY TO TAKE OVER THE COUNTRY.
>> YOU HAVE SWEDEN SUPPLYING
WEAPONS NOW.
GERMANY, A HUGE REVERSAL OF
GERMAN POLICY TO ACTUALLY NOW
SUPPLY WEAPONS.
THE QUESTION, I GUESS, IS CAN
THEY GET HERE IN TIME, AND CAN
THEY GET TO THE PLACES THEY'RE
NEED SGLD MY UNDERSTANDING FROM
TALKING TO U.S. OFFICIALS, THEY
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO KEEP THEIR
SUPPLY LINES OPEN.
LAND ROUTES, NOT COMING BY AIR.
RUSSIA LARGELY CONTROLS THE
AIRSPACE, BUT AGAIN, IT'S A
NUMBERS GAME HERE.
RIGHT, WHEN YOU LOOK AT TH